so you binge season to have stranger
things and got your fill of Eggos demo
dogs and snowballs but now you're
wondering what's next
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'm looking at what we
can expect from season 3 of the hit
Netflix show which means I've got a heap
of predictions and theories as well as
questions I'd love to see answered in
the series so I'll be discussing among
other things 11 the a/v Club gang hopper
Max and Billy Carly plus of course the
shadow monster by the way my stranger
things giveaway is also running on this
video so for your chance to win a
stranger things Funko pop make sure
you're subscribed to my channel and
leave a comment below about what you'd
like to see happen in season 3 obviously
I'll be discussing season 2 in detail
and referencing season 1 as well so take
care if you're not caught up before I
get into individual theories and
predictions for characters let's take a
quick look at what that creepy
cliffhanger the shadow monster / hawk in
school and the upside down means going
forward obviously it's an intriguing ly
menacing and ominous image to end on but
what really struck me about it was that
it feels like the monster is almost
stalking 11 and the a/v Club gang I mean
it stands to reason after all our heroic
friends were responsible for nixing the
mind flayers nefarious plan and driving
it and it's beastly minions out of their
town that's got to have riled up the
sinister creature so in season 3 I think
we could see the shadow monster making a
beeline for the kids especially 11 who
he witnessed actually closing the
gateway in Hawkins labs I also wonder
what happened to the portal in the
school corridor which 11 used to return
from the upside down this season it's
the same spot which the demo Gorgon used
in the first season to move from the
upside down to our world and if that
opening is still accessible then if
something the mine flare could use to
access Hawkins either way we're going to
see plenty more of the shadow monster as
the duffer brothers have confirmed it
will be an overarching villain for the
series as a whole by the end of the
second season 11 learned to control and
intensify our powers to the extend that
she was able to close an enormous breach
between the Hawkins lab and the upside
down and perhaps we'll see her powers
get even stronger as the series
progresses and she doubtless tracks down
other Hawkins lab survivors potentially
there's a bit more stability on the
horizon for Elle at least for the moment
and she's got
official birth certificate that gives
her a real name Jane hopper meaning that
chief hopper is now her official father
figure though she does go to the
snowball dr. Owens suggests that hopper
keep allowed to the spotlight for a year
which could fit in with the time jump to
1985 that I think we'll see next season
after all the do for others have talked
about the necessity of time jumps like
the one between seasons 1 and 2 as the
show's young actors are all growing up
and of course setting season 3 and 1985
we'd bring some great stuff for the show
to mine including Back to the Future
Fright Night and The Breakfast Club and
maybe after an off-screen year away from
prying eyes there with visits from her
friends we could even CL venture out in
the world joining Mike and the gang at
school and perhaps as Joyce and hopper
get closer we'll also see them all form
a sort of makeshift family then of
course there's still a couple of other
unresolved issues 411 which I expect
will also see addressed next season one
is with her sister Carly who she left in
Chicago and another is with her puffer
dr. Brenner who we just discovered
appears to be still alive and I'll talk
about those a little later in this video
season 2 introduces to two new
characters Max and Billy Max is a fun
addition who set up a new love triangle
with Dustin and Lucas vying for her
attention by the end though she'd proven
she could be a capable member of the AV
club party and expect that we'll see her
take on a much more active role next
season and given the influence of
Dungeons & Dragons on the show maybe
we'll see max he's pretty nifty on a
skateboard take on the role of a
Dungeons & Dragons rogue using her speed
and stealth to the group's advantage
Max's step-brother Billy was of course a
huge jerk throughout the season to the
point where it made me wonder why the
character was introduced as he's so
objectionable however I suspect that the
showrunners have something more
interesting in mind for him next season
which could also involve an affair with
mrs. wheeler Nancy and Mike's mum
another theory though is that Billy
could be co-opted willingly or not by
the mind flayer into working on behalf
of the evil entity Billy obviously has a
lot of issues this is relationship with
his bullying father his apparent racism
towards Lucas and he may still be
annoyed at Max or stabbing him with a
syringe in the finale all of those
things could take him to a dark place
where he ends up encountering the shadow
man
leading him to make a pact or just like
will he ends up taken over by the mind
flayer and gets used as a human spy and
if that were the case then this time the
shadow monster would be in control of
someone who was already a brutal bully
rather than the good-natured will and
Billy wasn't the only thing taken down
in the finale at the Byers house when 11
reunited with Mike and friends she took
out a set of demo dogs circling the
house but in a hilarious moment Dustin
then insisted that Steve's stuff one of
the dead demo dogs into the buyers
fridge because it's a groundbreaking
scientific discovery I'm hoping we might
see the AV party investigating the dead
creature as it could reveal something
more about how the mine flare controls
its hive minded minions and I wonder if
we'll see Dustin reach out to his
teacher mr. Clark for health opening
this new curiosity door
I mean mr. Clark has proven rather
helpful in the past for example giving
advice about making a sensory
deprivation tank so maybe he'd have some
tips about examining the demo dog or
maybe Steve and Dustin will continue
their newfound bromance into next season
with a demo dog dissection then again it
appears that dr. Owens is still in town
despite the closure of Hawkins lab and
he could well be interested in Dustin's
find despite his part in the cover-up
Owens did help hopper get a birth
certificate for 11 and so ended the
season on a positive note
but maybe Owens will turn out to be a
duplicitous scheming official similar to
actor Paul Reiser's character Carter
Burke in the movie aliens which was such
a big influence on this season of
stranger things oh and let's not forget
that the monster likes the cold so
although the demo dog is dead a fridge
may still not be the best place to keep
it speaking of Dustin the fact his nose
and mouth were covered by goggles and a
scarf in the tunnels didn't stop the
spray from a huge flower-like creature
getting in his mouth and hopper also got
sprayed and trapped by the vines when he
first entered the tunnels earlier in the
season
Owen don't forget that Mike also got
caught in the vines as well before being
rescued by his friends so potentially
any of those three characters could have
been infected by the monster they all
seem to be healthy at the end of the
season but we can't rule out there being
some sort of incubation period for any
infection they might be carrying as for
Willis will be interesting to see if he
still has been
the upside down in season 3 though the
differe brothers told variety that they
think they'll need to give will a
breather next season given everything
he's been through for the last two years
the appearance in season 2 of Carly aka
8 who's another young survivor of dr.
Brenda's secret experiments confirms
exactly what many of us were thinking
after last season but there are others
like 11 out there now it just remains to
be seen how many of those 10 he went
before 11 have survived I fully expect
to see a few of those survivors in
season 3 and beyond unlike al Carly is
based in Chicago and she also has
different powers to her lost sister
and she's able to make people see or not
see whatever she chooses so the question
for similar survivors going forward is
what they're up to now what their
particular powers will be and how and
were they will appear given that carly
was found in Illinois the state next to
Indiana I wonder if other survivors will
turn up in other surrounding states such
as Ohio Kentucky or Michigan also will
any of them join Carly on her revenge
mission for what I suspect will happen
in perhaps the final season is we'll
find them teaming up with 11 to
eventually overcome the terrors of the
upside down once and for all
I've got a separate video where I
explain all the clues in the show about
which new gifted children we'll see next
season you can tap in the top right to
watch that or there are links to it in
the video description and at the end of
this video before this season L assumed
dr. brenner was dead as the last time we
saw him the demo Gorgon appeared to be
pouncing on him in the school corridor
though the camera cut away before we
could confirm his fate in season 2 Papa
makes an eerie appearance when Carly
uses her powers to summon him up in Al's
mind but what's really exciting for
season 3 and Beyond is that former
Hawkins lab worker ray tells Elle and
Carly that Brenna is still alive and
that he can lead them to the man who
called himself their father of course
Carly and L are about to wreak revenge
on ray for what he did to them an owl's
mother at the lab so it's possible he's
lying to save his neck first if we take
Ray's confession at face value were is
Branagh hiding perhaps in Chicago like
his former lab assistant and what is
Brenna doing working on a number 12
maybe and will L be able to locate him
by herself it'll also be intriguing to
find out whether Branagh is actually
11th biological father or whether more
like
he was just encouraging her to think of
him as Papa as a convenient way for them
to bond and get her to do as he wished
the seventh episode wasn't as well
received as a rest of the show by many
fans as it felt somewhat jarring in
terms of the setting and characters but
what eleven learned from Carly was vital
for the finale however whether we'll see
Carly return might well depend on
whether the differ brothers feel she's
important for the final defeat in the
shadow monster and she could return as a
potential antagonist to eleven given
they departed on difficult terms however
they regard each other as sisters so
it's more likely they'll join together
next season to find and deal with dr.
Brenner now what do you want to see
happen in season three and what are your
favorite moments from this season let me
know what you think in the comments
below and also make sure you subscribe
to my channel for a chance to win my
stranger things giveaway enjoyed this
video then hit that like button and turn
on your notifications to get more videos
like this plus you can check out a
selection of my other videos here thanks
for watching and see you next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers